kenyans are struggling with rising food
and fuel prices but no expenses are
being spared in election campaigns
deputy president william ruto is one of
two main contenders
political alliances shifted dramatically
after he fell out with his boss outgoing
president uhuru kenyatta
ruto is among the candidates talking
about the cost of living but they're not
always explaining exactly how they'll
address it
we will organize the economy and reduce
the cost of living
his main opponent raila rodinga has run
for president four times before
many believe he's been rigged out of
some past election victories
this time the historically dominant
political establishment is backing him
up
[Music]
corruption is our number one enemy
kenyan's money goes into individuals
pockets outgoing president uhuru
kenyatta is among those backing raila
activists say kenyatta's government has
been even more corrupt than those that
came before it
ryla's promising change
ruto who's held the second most powerful
office in kenya for the last nine years
is also promising change
many kenyans are not convinced by
promises to tackle corruption it's a
card that they play sort of
i try and excite the public and get
voted but once they're in power we have
seen what they do when they have power
and none of that convinces me that they
have any will or any desire to fight
corruption
some previous elections were contested
largely along ethnic lines
this time the politicians are talking
more about policy especially compared to
the campaigns in 2007
those polls were followed by ethnically
targeted violence more than a thousand
people were killed you now have the main
tribes all
represented in the coalition so because
every vote counts
um
the parties do not have the luxury of
demonizing
any particular area
opinion polls put ruto slightly behind
ryla but with enough voters still
undecided to swing it
a significant amount of money is
expected to change hands in the final
stages of the campaigns kenyans are due
to vote in two weeks time
malcolm webb al jazeera kitangela kenya